in this video I want to finish up our
talk of the pentose phosphate pathway by
talking about a disease that relates to
it specifically glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase deficiency and hemolytic
anemia and how they play a role here so
glucose 6-phosphate dehydrogenase
deficiency is an x-linked disease such
as genetic disease and basically what
happens with this is that we have low
levels of glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase
and this of course is the enzyme that's
involved in the oxidative phase of the
pentose phosphate pathway so if we have
low levels we have a deficiency of this
enzyme we're going to have less
of this oxidative phase of the pentose
phosphate pathway and of course the
products of that pathway or the or of
that phase of the pentose phosphate
pathway where of course NADPH and ribose
5-phosphate the non oxidative phase
creates our 5p without creating an ad pH
so if we don't have g6p dehydrogenase we
could still create our 5p and then non
oxidative phase but as far as NADPH goes
we're probably going to have low levels
of NADPH some of the symptoms of this
deficiency are black urine jaundice
really low levels of hemoglobin and
really really high levels of red blood
cell death via humilis hemolysis so how
does this actually relate to the pentose
phosphate pathway specifically like in
more detail well what happens if we have
low levels NADPH low that if we have low
levels of NADPH that means we cannot
regenerate gsh which of course was the
reduced form of glutathione and that
acts acted as an antioxidant so if we
can't regenerate
GSH because we have low levels NADPH
we're going to have low levels of jsh
which means we have low levels of
antioxidants if we have less
antioxidants that means the oxidants
that do come in can destroy cells by
destroying biomolecules this of course
can lead to death now there are some
cells that are specifically harmed by it
or protect or more than others
red blood cells to be specific they're
especially hard by antioxidant or by
these by these oxidants and
the obvious thing is that the membranes
and the biomolecules are destroyed which
is something that we'd expect because if
there's if there's low gsh around we
can't fight off those oxidants but
further than that with red blood cells
low GH levels compromise the structure
of hemoglobin so hemoglobin it actually
depends on gsh to some extent to keep
its structure intact and when there's
low levels of G SH the structure of
hemoglobin is compromised and the then
we what happens is we have the
cross-linking of these hemoglobin
molecules and then we have the formation
of these things called Heinz bodies
Heinie's bodies on the red blood cells
so in case you're curious I conduct a
google search of that basically what
happens is that the red blood cells get
deformed so we have a red blood cell
deformity so they're deformed and this
is followed by cell lysis which of
course is basically just a cell
explosion so this is what we call
hemolytic anemia hemo of course
referring to the blood and oolitic
referring to lysis with a cell explosion
anemia is basically when you have either
two too little or too few red blood
cells or if you have too little or too
few hemoglobin so there's a hemolytic
anemia and that's what actually is the
term associated with this with what
happens here and that's what actually
killed these patients so how do we stop
this how do we how do we deal with this
well first and foremost you should know
if you have glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase deficiency and if you do
well you probably want to stay away from
oxidants right so if you stay away from
these oxidants so that they don't go in
and destroy your cells some things that
have a lot of fun a lot of oxidants are
fava beans in additions you want to stay
away from Pamuk win which is this anti
malaria drug and it can act it can
act as an oxidant so some patients who
have malaria one of the treatments is
Pamuk win and I hope I'm pronouncing
that correctly and if this is given to a
patient with glucose 6-phosphate
dehydrogenase deficiency the oxidants in
this drug could potentially kill the
patient so before this drug is
administered the patient must be
screened to see if they have that
deficiency on a final note I will note
that I'm not a doctor so if you have any
concerns about any of this please go see
your doctor I am by no means providing
medical advice here I'm just trying to
sort of look at this from an academic
academic perspective in any case I hope
that video was helpful and thank you for
watching hey folks my name is mo food
I am a tutor I graduated from UC
Riverside with a degree in biology and
on graduation to add a little bit of
trouble with the wind as you can tell
the subject I treated for our listed
here in the description below you'll
find my email address if you have any
questions and you'll also find the links
to to listing my university tutor
listing which is for in-person tutoring
and my Google helpouts listing which is
for online tutoring thanks for watching